[Musik]
james odmat ist Betriebsleiter der
wiesenbergbahn James heißt eigentlich
Hans aber weil es in der Gegend so viele
Hans odomat gibt nennen ihn alle
James
guten Tag James ich die
Seile fah
CIA allerdings hat James od seit vielen
Monaten
[Musik]
Ärger
die Bahn bleibt immer wieder
[Musik]
stehen
ma
zurfahren nach 80 me
sch stell automatisch ab
undfah
Schrank richtig
wieder fah
ja
[Musik]
schon
passier
wieder
ja stellt und man weiß es le vielleicht
h die verklipf oder h Angst oder mitmen
dan Sicherheit ich nmer
gewährleistet gefährlich ist die Störung
nicht aber James odomat muss die Kabinen
jedesmal zurück zum Start
bringen trotz großem Aufwand finden auch
die Experten den Grund für die Störung
nicht für alle ist klar es braucht
dringend eine
[Musik]
Sanierung bei der Bergstation oben in
Wisenberg wohnen 90 Personen es gibt
eine
Bergwirtschaft eine
Kapelle und viele
[Musik]
Bauernhöfe guten Morgen james ist der
Bruno
ich
super ich
B schönen Tag
Cam Bruno Niederberger Pendel zwischen
Alp und Hof aufidenaueben zum
re Haltestelle Brunos Vorfahren haben
die Zwischenstation hier in der Lady als
Entschädigung bekommen als das Bley 1934
auf ihrem Land gebaut
[Musik]
wurde das B sie D danke mit
dem mit der Vater und der
Großvater
mit ein das das ist
das ist a Kopf Weg den das geht zu der
Liegenschaft wie
wie es schon ja se Recht die
[Musik]
B
die Talstation in dallenvel Kanton
nitwalden die wiesenbergbahn ist ein
kleines Bley im großen Bahnland Schweiz
eine von insgesamt 2400 Seilbahnen hier
zu
Lande vom Tal geht es in 8 Minuten hoch
nach
Wiesenberg die zwei viererkabinen
befördern 16000 Fahrgäste pro Jahr
eine Besonderheit unterwegs gibt es drei
zwischenausstiege geht es aber nach den
ersten Sanierungsplänen fallen diese
zwischenausstiege Weg der Erhalt sei zu
teuer die Bahn würde nur noch die
Bergstation in Wiesenberg mit der
Talstation in dallenville
verbinden
die Nachricht hat Bruno Niederberger
erschreckt sein Hof Lady ohne
övanschluss
[Musik]
undenkbarich
mit das ist für
sie
groß
super ST die
Feri für mich als Bewirtschafter aber
mit der wenn ich h muss und das Band
hiereg der fahre ich Stunde Auto und sch
bin ich in der Viertelstunde da das ist
für
mich zeitparnis
wo ja eiglich nicht bezahlbar ist ich
hab Vorst schnell das wieer ist ein Ding
der
Unmöglichkeit probier möglich machen D
man das Geld
zuzlich man die das ist das wo das B
macht s
ich aber wie soll der
genossenschaftsvorstand das
finanzieren
die Sanierung kostet 1 Million
Franken für die Zwischenstationen kämen
je 100.000 dazu dabei kommt die kleine
Bahn schon jetzt kaum über die
Runden james odmat ist im Vorstand der
Bahn zusammen mit Schos Jolla die für
die Finanzen zuständig
ist danke viel
mal nehmen GL scharz ja
schstand da Hof ich ja 100000 Franken
wird sie auftreiben müssen praktisch in
frenarbeit für die Zwischenstationen
sieht sie schwarz also so
vi dem dass man jetzt das K aus der
passe
zahcha der
zufahrtstraß
und
diestationen W sind nmer so viel benutzt
worden klar sind gabig für sch od
jetztg
der aber es g nicht denke
ich einen zwischenausstieg gibt es auch
in
breiten für R der hier lebt ist die Bahn
mit vielen Kindheitserinnerung verbunden
wir
damit mit 7 jah wir
da tragen
oder zum Teil zweite h vielle oder wenn
schlift wenn nass Gras
Traktor oder wi
de ja zur Familie gehört auch Marie die
Mutter
von
im breit nacher gibt es eine ganze ble
Mappe mit
Erinnerungsstücken
ja
das ein Abbruch des zwischenausstiegs
für Marie
undenkbar das geht's nicht da bin ich
gerade
irgendwiepbstigange ich
ich
frem eigentlich nur einigermaßen gut GT
oder und das war schön da
bliieben oder ich bin nicht gewachsen
ich bin zuzog du hab wir no gar ke Straß
aus m mit dem Band Z geschleipt werde es
ist strank aber mir h gemacht und mir h
K zeigen W der Nick h Kand
geht vor z Jahr C
das und das ist no
eigentlich im
Vergleich wird sicher nicht mlich se
so zwischen Station rechten saber das
sicher nicht stammen mus einzige der
hier sage ich ja aber mir der hier oder
der Lady
ob
ja die dur ist selbst im bernley
Vorstand eine verzwickte
Situation viel Zeit bleibt nicht die
Sanierung muss rasch kommen die
Störungen häufen
sich
eine Z d
vi F mal am
Tag hier ein zwei D vi F mal die Bahn
ist ein
Stückwerk Getriebe und Antriebsrad haben
Jahrgang 99 das Rad
72 das Gestell 36 die Einzelteile sind
zwar in Ordnung aber zusammen mit der
Steuerung funktionieren sie nicht
mehrst plätzlich hup nicht F total das
ist letztte was ich hoffe war
Horrorszenario für
[Musik]
mir einmal pro Jahr trifft sich der
Vorstand der
seilbahnenossenschaft traditionell auf
der Alp des
[Musik]
Präsidenten
vorstandmlied zu
dem jetzt mus
ha let ist Siemer und ich hoffe das
bleib so mglich
geht zum TR
sonprekt ein wesentlicher Punkt ist ja
da mit der
zwischenustieg
FR
sztieg no ke Straße geh
undach der Luxus W
nochpruch
ja direkt betroffen da
die das ist nicht einfach sicher
Luxus Luxus s ich aber
oder die die sind
natürlich
meist
sie das
schonn wenn ich g WN von Million
red das ist nur schwierig das überhaupt
bringen das W verstanden dass mir
binierig zwischen
n
ma
ja
wer ist der
G
s immer
berichtsichtig für die
witterpl
mit
ja
eigent
aber
[Musik]
ja Kön von breiten nach fahren gut danke
von der Talstation schickt James odomat
die Kabine 2
[Musik]
hoch während Marie dur zum Einkaufen ins
Dorf
fährt warten weiter oben auf der
Zwischenstation Lady die
niederbergers
während der Schulferien fahren sie alle
zusammen auf die
Alp
ST ist der Vorteil mit
mus gchaff
nach nicht nur die Bahn auch die Straße
zwischen dallenville und Wiesenberg ist
ein Sanierungsfall sie wird ausgebaut
und ist während des Sommers
tagsübergesperrt die Sanierung wird noch
Jahre dauern wer in dieser Zeit mit dem
Auto hoch nach Wiesenberg will fährt
einen großen Umweg umso wichtiger ist
eine funktionstüchtige Bahn das ist
unbestritten
für die Zwischenstationen dagegen wie
hier im breitenache kämpfen nur die
Betroffenen Problem W ich g ist sind
eentlich nur meh zwe oder und das wird
sicher nicht einfach da
irgend stimmig machen das oder eine
entscheidigung jahrlich einmalig oder
seit das Band das ist le und
recht
wenig von der Bergstation geht es für
niederbergers zu Fuß weiter auf die
Alp 20 Minuten dauert der
[Musik]
Marsch ich schel
oh die bahnsanniierung reißt einen
Graben auf in der kleinen Gemeinschaft
ander
schlechthaup nicht fr sind verhärtet
aber wir sind ja nicht verkracht g D man
du ist einfach die
normale
auseinandersetz normale
meinsvchiedenheit
ganz so entspannt sehen es nicht
[Musik]
alle
hallo
jawoh
[Musik]
dankeösung
se aushelfen hat James
od
ja
ganz komisch
Spezi offiziell bin
nichtell jahrelang hat James omat oben
in Wiesenberg den Bauernbetrieb seiner
Eltern geführt bis ihn eine asthmatische
Krankheit bremste erst dann vor 10
Jahren wechselte er zur Bahn
eine Aufgabe aber hat er noch immer in
Wiesenberg der Hof der odmatz gleich
neben der Wiesenberger Kapelle muss den
sierist Stellen das ist in einem
sogenannten Servitut vertraglich
festgelegtorben ist vor 50
Jahre das doch du machen und so wie
schon 50 jah sie mit 13 hat er das Amt
übernommen
mus als James ein boob war gab es in der
Kapelle Wiesenberg jeden Tag eine Messe
keinen Sonntag konnte er einfach freim
machen über die Jahrzehnte nahm die Zahl
der Gottesdienste ab heute gibt es noch
einen
wöchentlich die Kapelle ist für ihn wie
eine zweite
Wohnstube
Freid Leid
[Musik]
erlt
schön
Winter ist wirklich für mich ist es
eigentlich
[Musik]
sch bald wird jamesom nicht mehr direkt
bei der Kapelle aussteigen können mit
der Sanierung wird auch diese
Zwischenstation geschlossen so der Plan
betroffen wäre auch der Kaplan
[Musik]
genau es steht die jährliche
Generalversammlung der
seilbahnenossenschaft an der Vorstand
ist gefordert
B Geschichte das
ist schwierig man nicht einfach wenn das
garenlochen und
und da mus
Bewilligung
B jedes
Mal
ja
[Musik]
schon der vorstandute neuigiten diechene
sind no nicht g
cha
undcha das ist Ende August
2021 genossenschafin und
Genossenschafter g wor
sch dringend notwendige
sonierigsmaßnahme rech wir Mitte V ein
Million Schweizer Franken mit der
Eigenmittel ver hoffentlich zwe Drittel
von der gesamtcheste BLE nurum 300000
Frank wo andere weag beschaffen wird in
Zukunft wieder die Ausstieg g da das im
Gesamt K von rund
300000 Franken aus maach werde wir
Kredit
berage wo die Austieg nichterechnet sind
mir werd im Rahmen vom Projekt
prüfen optional vorgeseh dass die
Austieg nachtraglich könnte ausgerüet
werden gerade Frage zu zu der
Finanzier Paul oder vielleicht ist irg
seitstelle die
zwe und das n bringen
[Musik]
empflen euch derenschaft
Berggemeinden
schrie Vorsitzende
Hz kamer von ich würde mit
persönlichüft darf
nur
Institution schwe
das ma aber sicher nur eine
prüfemind relativ viel Geld im Jahr ca
25 Millionen W das ganz Andes Kaliber
als gut wurde wir
abstimmen
ich danke derrag
ist
eintimmig der große Sanierungskredit ist
genehmigt ohne Zwischenstation aber
immerhin will der Vorstand klären ob die
Ausstiege nachträglich wieder in Betrieb
gehen
[Applaus]
könnten se ja
Nachbar Bruno Niederberger ist nicht
Genossenschafter hatin und wird
drin
ja wenn es so
bleibt es liegt Hoffnung in der Luft an
diesem
[Musik]
Abend Wiesenberg feiert
heuteilbi mit
freiluftgottesdienst mus
machen dan und
tstellen
undar vertrage
undus was brucht V der ne
vertrage der Alpenhof etwas oberhalb der
Bergstation
abmittag wird die Gaststube zum Zentrum
des festsste Schublade aber H mikrow
der kleine kan Gisler ist zum ersten Mal
dabei seine Mutter Jan Gisler wohnt seit
5 Jahren im Alpenhof sie will
Vorstandsmitglied der Bahn
werden das Fieber hat die Berner
Oberländerin
angesteckt
Buss
busverbut
für mich geh aber irg
wir und sie
so selbständig wer sie müss selber bed
sie
müss ja und ich find cool
mit in G Wohnstube im ersten Stock wärmt
sich der berühmte Wiesenberger Jod für
die
auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
janinmann Florian judelt
mit
[Musik]
der Chor gehört zu Wiesenberg wie die
bgemin bekannt
für se W hierachs Sie also hätte schon
ein emotionale bed
[Musik]
das in 5 Minuten ist man von der
Bergstation zu Fuß in der
[Musik]
Kapelle Herr herbe dich her ere
dich
heilig
her
hig
Istan
hik
[Musik]
éar
in der Küche krampfen der Wal die Eltern
Gisler Helen und
egal welche Generation hier hat jede und
jeder eine Geschichte mit dem
[Musik]
berley
wichtig
bin ich n bin ich
wieder zwe
mal
ein paar Wochen später ist klar die
zwischenausstiege lassen sich auch
nachträglich nicht mehr machen der
Hoffnungsschimmer der letzten GV ist
verschwunden die Stützen müssten viel
stärker gesichert werden als dies heute
der Fall ist die Auflagen sind nicht
abzuschätzen eine Delegation muss die
Nachricht
überbringen neben den
Vorstandsmitgliedern dabei auch Patrick
Enz von der seilbahnfirma von Rotz und
widemar er hat das Fachwissen in die
Diskussion
gebracht erste Station breite
nacher ich mus
immer relich begr Familie
dur
ja s mir zum Schluss es GT einfach
irgendwie wie nicht also technisch
machbar finanziell sehr schwierig
rechtlich und
bewilligungstechnisch unabwgbar im
Moment es ist einf mir da wie truen auf
der Zwischenstation in breit nach dass
das stat in solange die Bahn betrieben
wird das die Zwischenstation muss
eentlich betrieben
werde ja mich stell sich Frage ja was
ist was oder nicht das die
Zwischenstation immer was n mich das
Bandl oder V der ich w B in der quer ST
das nicht aber ja sind einfach
gedankenang wo man h oder wir sind do in
Zwick
s schon
lang die Männer müssen weiter sie wissen
bei Nachbar Bruno Niederberger wird es
schwieriger
ja ja nicht ganz gleich
aber ich mer zum
Gl
kN
mer mus mus hert bliben her Beben nicht
Wied sagen ja ja gut prüfen wir nomal
prüfen ja das ist schwierig das
[Musik]
ist
sind Entscheid
über das n
maon
ja das Problem ist eigentlich
W jetzt macht zu später zpunkt
wird ein Neubauprojekt nach der
Sanierung um die Zwischenstationen
wieder aufzubauen viel zu aufwendig und
teuer aber Bruno Niederberger will es
nicht akzeptieren die Diskussion dreht
sich weiter um die 200000 Franken
Zusatzkosten für die
zwischenaege Milli
nein
absolut da da sch ge
200 ist mir
Meinig da bin ich 100prozentig sicher
wenn der
GF Millionen jeder Hand es g hier um es
hier um das Gebiet wo so schnell
erschlossen war wir haben das hinter weo
wo
vi und für ist es so
sehr emotional
wirklich das ganze Projekt
ja schon verhaltnismäßig so eine
zwischenustieg so W hier verhanden
öffentlich zu
machen also da ist nicht klar od das ist
nicht nicht absteckbar im
Moment
SPI
geht schwe das
ist ja was heißt
das
ich
gut die Vorstandsmitglieder wollten hart
bleiben stattdessen ließen sie wieder
Hoffnung
aufkommen sind
dietiege Ciao
James aber die Woche verstreicht es sind
keine Geldgeber zu finden Bruno
Niederberger kann die Zwischenstation
nicht
retten
Steade die Bahn macht mittlerweile was
sie
will dass es abst wenn man
Abfahrt eigentlich schon
länger
aberere es ist jetzt zwei dreal vor dass
ich
zwischenstationfahre zum
le und einach nichtemt das istfahen
Ende
2021 die Spenden lassen auf sich warten
das Projekt wird kontinuierlich teurer
die Kassierin
kämpft
Sch
so
s fen und Z hin
gemt sch recht schwierig das das
bewalen H solange
no
grö od
irgendw die H mus Betrieb stell z.B oder
settige
[Musik]
Sache seine Lieblingsjahreszeit aber
lässt sich James ODM nicht
[Musik]
verderben jetzt die letzte
Jahr mach ich eigentlich allein
n Firmling aber das Jahr ist
offenbar
[Musik]
sich im Mai 22 steht wieder eine GV
an und kncha Herz willkommen
ch J
Betrieb einiger Zeit
wier
vorstandolleg re vor kurz sie
charakterak 2 Millionen Franken mit den
1,2 Millionen sind wir sicher dass wir
die bahnön sier und jetzt ich
NUB Schweizer partnenschaft für
Berggemeinden letzte GV im August ist H
Schneider der Tip
dochich das wir
gemacht Spende
zuicher sage und schreibe
250000 Franken
versprochen die Sanierung ist auf guten
Wegen für den Vorstand Zeit für eine
Erneuerung zur W W mir ich vorschl sch
geslerhofberg ist sch
gerade D sie
WIS verhieratet mit Florian vomhof
und
sie und ihr zweit
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
unterwachs die wiesenbergbahn
pannenanfällig
[Musik]
weiter erst im Januar
2023 startet endlich die
Sanierung die globalen Lieferengpässe
haben sich bis in den kantonitwalden
ausgewirkt der Zeitplan ist
eng die Bahn muss wieder in Betrieb
gehen bevor die Straße am 1 Mai wie
jedes Jahr geschlossen
[Musik]
wird also ich
bfed
also los gangen ist vor z D Wochen ich
schlafezwischen sch
besser
sehr viel SP
dan
tschüserwartet und S
total allein bei der partenschaft
Berggemeinden haben sich die Spenden
inzwischen verdoppelt waren es an der
letzten GV noch 250000 Franken sind es
mittlerweile fast
[Musik]
was die Zwischenstationen betrifft nützt
der geldsen aber nichts mehr sie lassen
sich nicht ins laufende Projekt
einfügen es bräuchte ein neues
Bewilligungsverfahren
ja ja nicht
so
ja
schade
[Musik]
technisch wird anders se
od
Computer mßig und immer das Mus und so
sondern
Streich
t Stream
od
in der Lady hat Bruno Niederberger den
Abbruch der Zwischenstation verpasst er
arbeitet im Winter auswärts als
gibser
Helikopter
H
ja ist
fort33and
ja erst in den letzten Tagen hat er
entdeckt dass der Anspruch auf eine
Zwischenstation im Grundbuch
festgehalten
ist sind die
Vertrag
durchleitungsvertrag die Bahn darf nur
über das Land fahren wenn ein ein und
Ausstieg geboten wird
mircht das das das Hand und oder wie das
ist bin ich Jurist ja wenn es Stre
vielleicht git's g
Franken wo man
[Musik]
jetztf Lack für die alten
Gondeln das ist jetzt die
nächste hier bereit
Geschwindigkeit kann man da auf B
reduzieren bring ich wieder zum
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Fahren die wiesenbergbahn fährt jetzt an
der Kapelle vorbei der Ausstieg ist
gesperrt ist für mich Bild für der we l
vielleicht
gottisch wir b um das Sage von der Bahn
als Ganzes und von der Kabine wir bitten
um die Sage für die
MTE im Namen des Vaters und des Sohnes
und des Heiligen
Geistes
[Musik]
Amen Projekt ist
abgeschlossen ein Erfolg für die
Verantwortlichen mit dem Abbruch der
Zwischenstationen sind sie im
rein richtig gemacht ich
glaube das langfristige große
[Musik]
belast die
sicherheitsvorkeh so enorm
also im nachhineinn sag vielleicht war
das hat das Gang
ja aber es war einfach schon ein Top und
in dem Moment W müen entscheiden ist
halt ich halt das Geld noch nie da und
nicht während der Einweihung ist Bruno
Niederberger auf der Alp mit dem neuen
vorstandspräsident der Bahn versteht er
sich gut trotz der komplizierten
Situation wir sehr gut die
sprach
sie sie sind irgendwo 100 Frank pro Jahr
wo wcheidigung Zahl mir sind irgendwo
1500 fr
sage wenn sie natürlich extrem große
Schritt nach G sind mir mitm Rechtschutz
so verblieben
maximum mus hol das notl muss machen und
das muss möglich schnell und H einfach
nicht bis hin prüft und der ist mein
mein
worden die Bahn fährt jetzt
pannenfrei aber der Graben den die
Sanierung aufgerissen hat ist noch nicht
zugeschüttet
[Musik]
die auch ber
und sehen eigentlich
ob das ist nur
[Musik]
Gig
ο
[Musik]